how do you do nice to meet you Jim I've
never done speed dating but this looks
like the long now not quite like speed
dating it's a publicly exposed long
speed dating yeah miss all right don't
worry so it's lovely to meet you I
purposely I've never taken part in one
of these long conversations before but
I've witnessed them and I always thought
what was interesting about them as a
premise was the idea that people didn't
know each other at all and met like this
so I purposely didn't find anything out
about you except I know from
accidentally reading something you're an
inventor and and also that you invented
some special lenses this is true so I I
am an engineer when you said I was one
of those kids who took everything apart
yes so was I yeah I just persisted until
I eventually could put it back together
yeah that's probably the the only
difference yeah and well that's
admirable it's a peculiar type of OCD I
think yeah so one of the things I was
very interested in grad school was how
do you make how do you make lenses
cheaper for providing eyeglasses or not
tell me care in developing world and we
built a pre neak
membranes to cast lenses so I know a
little bit more about you because I went
to one of your concerts Oh a long-player
concert or a different type of Pogues oh
one of those long time ago yeah one of
those really fast concerts that's over
and done with
well I'm just a heart back to lenses
it's funny to be actually meeting you
because I just was given four boxes of
lenses by an optician
of a gloss old-fashioned lenses plastic
lenses glass lenses all different focal
lengths shapes and sizes because he
learned that I was making a camera
obscura how fabulous and wanted to get
involved in you know helping me out and
I've been obsessed with a part of this
whole long player thing sort of led to
wanting to make something that didn't
went on but didn't need looking after
we're going in the direction of the long
photograph yeah I think well what we're
going in the direction of is how do you
make something that you don't have to
look after and I figured that you may be
light is the best thing because just the
fundamental laws of physics are such
that if you use light and a pinhole
you're going to get something that will
just work yes yeah and but the stumbling
block was how to get a lens because I
thought you needed to get very expensive
lenses ground so you actually don't need
any lens for your obscura you could do
it all with pinhole yeah yeah no well
anyway to cut a long story short I did I
did get told that you could just use
opticians lenses and but I was
interested in making a kind of spherical
surround vision camera obscura not not
one there projected on a table but a
whole immersive one now I built it oh
it's done yeah well it was in a park in
Cheshire and it will be in another park
in the South of England from March it's
like inside a big stainless steel sphere
with a lens if you imagine the equator
of the sphere it's got like
every hundred and twenty degrees so
three lenses so they project onto the
inside of the sphere and kind of overlap
in strange ways and projected so
literally you're inside it and you're
kind of above the clouds and below the
water you literally turn the world
inside I love that idea
yeah I was actually intrigued when
Jewett was talking to you so you built
this instrument that plays a song that
you'll never hear yeah I was wondering
whether you just sped it up and and
listened through it once just to satisfy
yourself I mean don't you want to know
as an artist that it doesn't screw up at
the 4 millionth bar no I mean that
that's kind of what I like is that I
know how it began and I know how it ends
because the end is the same as the
beginning because it's a loop and and I
like the idea that it's full of
surprises and I know that a lot of those
surprises are going to be really
unpleasant and the thing that does sort
of concern me is about having these live
concerts is that those moments could
happen for an entire thousand minutes in
public and I could look like a complete
idiot which possibly I look like
anywhere I don't know but it's because
that's the nature of the thing Posthumus
idiocy is less bad yeah no I I've always
resisted any temptation to leap forward
into the future and see what it sounds
like but I'm learning to sort of
understand what it might sound like by
by experience you know the thing about
the life thing as you can see where the
bits of the score are very explicitly
and how they combine and so I can
imagine what might happen when they move
in different ways so it sounds like
you're you're you're very interesting
now I mean if you're gonna design music
that lasts that long you're you have to
be interested in algorithms yes I'm I'm
explicitly interested in algorithms
yeah for a different reason go on then
so Galileo I as I with an amateur
version of the history of science would
say that Galileo really started all when
he said that we should measure
everything that's measurable and modern
and make miserable what is not I think
that was fantastic for science through
the last few centuries we we now
understand the large scale the universe
and the very small scale of structure at
an atomic level and subatomic level
because we did single parameter
experiments and measured these things
and I think I'm really interested in the
long view of science that we almost need
a statement now that rather than
measuring this mesh well we should model
everything that's model able and make
model of all what is not because we now
can compute these things I think this is
a significant transition for science
because it's not just about
understanding the physical world up to
the present moment
it's about predicting the physical world
beyond the present moment I think it has
a lot of interesting ramifications so
I'm really into modeling everything can
actually also again while you were
talking made me think of solo it's hard
work like he was the he was the first
guy to really do it in something right
sounds like you can execute his program
for a thousand years yeah
like the drawings yeah I mean I pity the
interns that have to do it but they add
another thing it must be great doing
that thousands of lines yeah it's part
of my condition but so what what have
you been modeling I don't want to
modeling on energy at the moment so how
do you solve the near-term energy
problem in the context of carbon and how
do you think about energy further out so
that's an example of modeling the future
I guess and then some things I'm
modeling a lot of lenses at the moment
for solar applications and then modeling
actually steering mechanisms for
bicycles of all things are tricycles
what I really like about this modeling
thing and I think again it's
it could it could be an interesting
extension of science right now I really
believe and a friend of mine says it
better than me that every paper that we
write or every piece of knowledge we
were write down should actually be an
executable file so that that you can see
everything that the person did so that
the model should be the publication and
I love this because everything is
embedded in that everything all of your
knowledge and all of your assumptions
and that would be a great way to carry
knowledge forward and to build knowledge
in a in a faster more interesting way
than we we do now where you publish it
and it's people who publish these papers
do a reasonable job of saying what they
did but it's always difficult to really
understand everything they knew at that
time I'm interested in algorithms and
modeling for for this you're giving me a
look like this is the worst date I've
ever been on no actually it's quite a
good day this but I'm sorry if I was
giving you a look it's probably
something a bit spaced out because I've
been up since about half plus five and
been on been deprived of food and
nourishment and no I I was also probably
giving you that look because I was
trying to visualize what you're saying
and make sure I understood it which is
that you're actually making explicit
instead of basically giving someone a
paper that's full of equations and stuff
you're giving them something they can
explicitly see you're giving them the
program executes all those equations and
then they can see all yeah you can see
what it actually looks like and they can
see the garbage or the good stuff that
you put into the equations and then it
would just be more rapid progress
because rather than having to then go
and build that own model themselves they
start with yours I think would be a
lovely way to so they hand knowledge
through but I mean yeah I can I
understand that but I was just wondering
about it must be possible to model lots
of things they're actually impossible
physically impossible
and yeah impossible for the laws of
physics etc etc which I've got nothing
against but I just wondered how you know
how you do the weeding in your system oh
if people then tried I think I think
many eyes looking at it will say this is
impossible and they'll they'll construct
a good reason they'll say you know you
chose the wrong values for gravity and
the mass of a neutron so this is
impossible
I think would be a faster way to improve
do you think do you think with your
lenses you could make lenses that can
kind of compete with radio telescopes
for looking back to the beginnings of
the universe I've actually read this
paper this morning
you're all gonna laugh at me but it's
true so the particular way that this
machine worked is everyone has seen a
droplet of water on the leaf that's it's
a minimum energy surface and and
depending upon how you constrain the
boundaries of that droplet so whether it
wets the leaf and lies flat or whether
it balls up you can actually change the
optical properties of that leaf you can
also do this with a membrane so that the
children's version is you take a you
take a cup you stretch cling wrap over
the top and then you suck a little bit
of air out and that will make a
beautiful lens shape surface and so
there are there are people at NASA and
JPL who think about doing this for a
Space Telescope's
so rather than launch this enormous
heavy heavy lens or mirror up into space
you launch in fact a an inflatable metal
metallized mylar it's like a thin
plastic film with a layer of mirror on
it so you've launched this inflatable
bag you inflate it and then it becomes
this perfect lens and and it looks like
they will be able to perform just as
well or perhaps even better than
telescope lenses but do you think
they'll be able to see back like you
know like his new array of radio
telescopes that like compound eyes that
can look back to you know the Cosmic
Microwave Background do you think you it
would be possible to actually we're way
and we're way out of my mind
technical oh sorry well I revealed but I
mean you so well I'm probably talking a
bit you know simplistically and with the
vague layman's understanding but as I
understand it the you know if we the Big
Bang happened or if that was the way the
universe started that there's this
residual background radiation right
which started when the universe cooled
down sufficiently for information to
start passing through it and so these
new generation of radio telescopes are
sort of looking back at the CMB and you
know well back towards that to pick out
you know the earliest sort of clouds of
gas forming into stars and stuff I just
wondered if it would ever be possible to
make an optical telescope in your
opinion that could do that so you can't
look beyond the speed of light that
there is a boundary of the universe that
you can see this is Martin this is my
high school physics yeah but surely a
radio telescope so so he is I think
maybe we answer the question you can you
always want to make a bigger and bigger
lens you see further back to increase
the the sort of resolution that you can
see back and this is a way to make
increasingly big lenses with less
material it's also the reason we make a
lot of these as a raise of telescopes
now so you don't you know it's a little
hard to make a single mirror that's two
miles yeah in diameter so they use lots
of little ones like a fern L lens which
was originally developed by the French
for lighthouses yeah and then you add up
all those little pieces yeah this this
would be a way potentially make cheap
the
of that in fact some of those that I
really care about energy they're they're
actually retiring some of these solar
plants that are lots and lots and lots
of mirrors you know to be used for
astronomical observation now serve with
the these were built in the 70s to test
ideas in solar energy and now they're
useful for space science which I think
it's nice
I'm obsessed I think we need we need to
solve our energy problems here in the
near term I said that we can work it out
your what do you think could do that
there's certainly a lot of solar energy
there's a lot of wind energy you could
do it for a while on nuclear power but
nuclear is the the the materials that
you would use there's only a limited
amount so it'll probably last a thousand
years but probably not a lot further
fusion will give us a little bit more
than that but but at the moment I think
you know fusion is it still unproven so
we're gonna be stuck with solar and and
and the the subsidiaries of solar like
wind and biofuels I once went to a talk
by an economist called I think it's
called jeremy Rifkind and he was talking
about hydrogen fuel cells I consciously
don't go to talks with with economists
yeah well I went to this job for
whatever reasons you know yeah I'm so is
very fascinating to me because he was
talking about energy revolutions
following or happening at the same time
as communications revolutions right and
so he was talking about you know that
the Internet is being this communication
revolution of you know decentralized
Network communication and cell phones
too and waiting for the the energy
revolution that would go with it and he
was talking about hydrogen fuel cells in
the context of they would be a
decentralized form of energy the erector
yes so they're yeah he's got to be
careful this is why I gotta talks will
anonymous it's a battery not a energy
source like you have to produce the
hydrogen some other way yeah no he did
he did so they say that was the snag
that you know hydrogen doesn't grow on
trees the thing that you have to you
have to crack the hydrogen out of
something else but I mean he it was a
persuasive and interesting ID
and you know he gave lots of examples
that made it sound like something would
one would like to see but then I've
always been surprised that never really
heard much about it since then yeah it's
definitely the Holy Grail is the
distributed energy source unfortunately
in my life I actually looked at these in
detail and if I covered by a hole every
piece of land that I owned in my life
and it was producing hydrogen perfectly
it still wouldn't cover the amount of
energy that I use I'm a little worried
that that's sort of my mission at the
moment is what what is the limits what
is a reasonable amount of energy for
each person on the planet and in the
context of carbon and these other things
how do you how do you live the highest
quality of life at per unit of energy so
it actually makes the energy climate
change conversations of an aesthetic one
how do you know this is like how do we
get the most out of what we know is
finite well you'll have to carry that on
with the next person else right anyway
it's been lovely talking to you yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you